Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa.
I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our
17th episode.
Moco-chan, that's almost 30 episodes.
Ruffians!
It's still a bit far away, but it's closer.
It's closer to 30 episodes.
We're close to 30 episodes now.
Episode 17.
I saw that there's some ruffians that are joining us for the first time today, so please let me explain.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
Spells out FUWAMOCO!
And is hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I love ruffians!
It's a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
Has there been any ruffians that might have seen Pero?
I think we have another Pero Sighting!
Where was he again?
Let's see.
This is a very different Pero Sighting.
This Ruffian's brother brought Pero.
Why would you do that?
Right, it's kind of questionable, but you know, I guess they're maybe doing it out of the goodness of their heart.
A kind Ruffian.
Right, you know, like rescue Pero and bring him back to us.
That makes sense, I guess, yeah.
But now he can't find his brother.
Huh?
Has he gone missing?
Do you see anything in this picture that could be a clue, Ruffians?
I see Pero.
Yeah, Pero's there.
Yeah, he looks like his normal self.
Yeah, he looks pretty comfy on your bed.
Yeah, yeah.
And he's admiring himself in your big mirror.
Aw, nice!
Why?
It's nice to have a mirror.
I wonder what he's thinking as he looks at himself in the mirror, you know?
I'm round.
Like, maybe like...
A little bit more like that kind of thing.
I should try to lose some weight.
Because he's round.
He's thinking his next move.
I need more bones!
Is that a thought that you have too, Ruffians?
Is that a self-improvement?
I need more bones.
I should get some more bones in my body.
I wonder though, with all those kind of anxieties, what kind of motivation does Pero have for self-improvement?
Maybe that's why he's going so many different places and not staying here with us.
Self-improvement!
Thank you for bringing him in, Ruffians!
We said that he enjoyed your bed.
It looks very fluffy!
And I'm sure if you found Pero, I'm sure you'll find your brother again.
Very, very good at finding things.
Right, Ruffians?
Hang in there!
BAU BAU!
Please, Ruffians, let us know if you see Pero, okay?
Remember to use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING if you spot him, okay?
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
That was kind of a different one, right Moco-chan?
Well, I think some Ruffians may not, but we do have a super fun weekend ahead of us!
You know we have the Japanese Classroom with Advent and our Rock n' Rawr Party, but... Tomorrow!
Tomorrow!
Not today.
What's tomorrow, Moco-chan?
We are having our very first membership stream for the Doggy Pack!
Membership with the Doggy Pack!
Well, Ruffians, if you're part of the Doggy Pack, we think you might have seen our cute emos.
You've been enjoying them, right?
Doggy Pack has been, but if you join the Doggy Pack we have a bunch of cute emotes and membership badges.
Membership badge, maybe there's some Ruffians that aren't too sure, but the membership badge goes with you as you are a member of the Doggy Pack.
And then the emotes, they're just cute and we can use them all together.
We can BAU BAU and you win.
But, you know,
We're planning to have even more emotes in the future, so we hope that you'll look forward to those ones too.
But more importantly, we have our first membership stream.
Yes, what is it, Moco-chan?
Battle plan!
We're gonna be having a battle plan, you know?
And we wanted to do something special.
You know, something that would be comfy, where we can get close together.
And we thought it would be a good time to take a moment to sit down and kind of figure out a battle plan all together.
Because Ruffians, you remember during our debut we had a big list of goals and dreams, right?
Yeah, all our goals and dreams, right?
Yeah.
Well, we're working on making this happen, but we wanted to sort of know what you think you'd like to see first.
Because we can't focus on everything at once, right?
There's over a hundred of them.
So let's take little steps towards some at a time.
I'm curious though, I want to know which ones you're most excited for us to accomplish all together.
So let's all put our heads together and figure out what we can do to make them come true, okay?
Ruffians, make sure you start planning now, okay?
It's tomorrow, so... Are you just trying to make them do all the work?
No, it's a group effort, you know?
We can accomplish our dreams all together, no?
We can't just do it the two of us.
FUWAMOCO alone... No.
We need the ruffians.
So, on that note, you know, maybe you're not a part of the Doggy Pack yet,
I would say just from a personal standpoint, not as Fuwawa, that it would be a very good time to join.
Because you won't miss our first stream then.
And we've already done a couple little things, but we have some plans to make the Doggy Pack pretty special.
You might not know what it is.
We recommend.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Let's plan ahead, okay?
We're looking forward to it.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Next!
Well... Unfortunately... There's been another misunderstanding.
Why do we keep on having misunderstandings?
Why?
I guess... Ah, that's right.
This time... This time it wasn't our misunderstanding.
It wasn't the Ruffians' misunderstanding.
It was Abyss' misunderstanding.
You know?
They think that Fuwawa doesn't exist and it's just a part of my imagination.
I know.
You know, in the Minecraft collab we had the other day, the Advent members, they started to say that Fuwawa doesn't exist and that she's just a part of my imagination.
But, you know, I've also seen other comments saying that we're just two parts of a gamer.
The backseater and the toxic one.
No!
And that's not true either.
Not true.
You know, Fuwawa exists.
She's right here!
Ruffians, I'm real, right?
You understand, right?
You believe me?
I'm real?
You don't have to ask the ruffians if you're real.
I just want to check, you know?
You just want to check?
Who's Fuwawa?
Why do you keep on saying that, ruffians?
I don't know what to believe anymore.
She's right here!
She's on my right!
I mean my left!
Yeah, left.
I guess I could kind of see how the other avid members felt like I was just a voice in their heads when we were, you know, playing Minecraft?
Yeah, yeah.
We only have Moco-chan's body on screen, so yeah, it would be maybe a bit confusing.
Yeah, I guess.
Well, hopefully we'll have a solution to this misunderstanding soon, but for now, Ruffians!
You understand, right?
You don't, right?
The huawawa's here.
No more huawawa!
She's here with us.
I'm in this room!
I'm in the studio this morning!
It's okay, Mococo!
Understood!
Yes!
Good!
Understood.
I'm still concerned.
Why?
Moco-chan.
I don't know what to believe anymore.
But... For now... I guess we're okay.
I believe in my life!
It's real!
Okay, okay.
You believe in me like the support kind, not like the I believe in ghosts kind, right?
Ruffians?
Yes, yes.
BAU BAU!
No more misunderstanding.
It's good.
Understood.
Next!
Ruffians, we'd like to have Moco-chan share something very important with you.
Maybe a new corner?
Well, you know, before you head out today, I think, you know, Moco-chan, it'd be good if she kind of lets you know what to prepare for, you know?
Like if you need to prepare for the day.
Yeah, like if you need an umbrella with you, if you should dress in short sleeves, because it's time for...
Moco-chan's Knees Plank!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you for that wonderful introduction, my sister and fellow announcer, Fuwawa.
Well, you're welcome.
Yes, you're welcome.
Yes, like discussed in this corner, I, Mococo Abyssgard, will alert you to upcoming and important news which will affect your life and your heart very deeply.
Listen up, because it's time for Moco-chan's Sneeze Forecast.
Today, the forecast calls for...
A very sunny and sneezy time.
But it seems like some sort of pressure system continues throughout the area.
Hopefully we will have relief throughout the weekend.
But you know how the weather and allergies can be sometimes, you know?
But we will keep you posted regarding further updates on the sneeze forecast.
Thank you.
This has been a Moco-chan sneeze forecast.
Now back to my sister, Fuwawa Abyssgard.
This is Mococo Abyssgard, signing off.
Did you enjoy my professional sneeze forecast?
Very, very much.
Right?
Professional transitions, right?
Yes.
I think it was a...
A sneezy day the other day, right?
Just a bit.
Maybe this weekend too.
Never know with the weather.
Right?
The sneeze forecast, right?
Well, I think all the Ruffians may know what else we have planned for today, right?
Right, it's a very important day today.
It's the day, Ruffians!
It's the day!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's time for...
FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle!
Today, we'll be deciding on the jingle that we'll be using during FUWAMOCO Morning from every day on!
Are you excited?
Well, you know, a little more than a week ago, we asked you Ruffians for an original jingle for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We wanted to be able to make something special all together since FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that, you know,
It's us and you.
It's a show we make all together.
That's why we're asking for your submissions.
We're always asking for your submissions.
It's very important to us.
It's us together.
That's what FUWAMOCO Morning is.
We're just hosting it.
We thought that a jingle made by you would be the perfect thing to start our show.
We really wanted to say thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you so much for all your submissions!
It's a group effort together, right?
We really love listening to every single one of them!
Once more, please let us say a big, big thank you to every single ruffian that made a jingle for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We really appreciate it.
It was really hard to select just one.
It really, really was!
We weren't fighting, nope.
Each one is so unique and wonderful.
It has a Ruffian's personality.
I've had so many stuck in my head!
Very, very good.
Ruffians are just very, very impressive.
Right?
First, we'd like to showcase some more jingles with you today.
Since today is the last day, we have quite a number of them.
Are you ready?
I'm going to listen to them.
So you have to be like this, okay?
Put your headphones on, listen very closely, okay?
First, today we have a jingle from this ruffian.
From Mighty Junkie!
Let's have a listen, Moco-chan.
They definitely caught the energy and the feeling of waking up to a new morning with FUWAMOCO Morning!
So cute.
I feel like I could skip to it, you know?
Skip?
You know, and Moco-chan was like, oh we should have a jingle that's like... Right?
Right?
Maybe, yeah.
Yeah, but you know, I feel like it has a little bit less of that, which is good!
Because I feel like that could be like a dubstep morning.
What's wrong with Unchinomorning?
I don't think that's quite...
Quite maybe what at least I was envisioning, but... I really, really like it.
Thank you!
Thank you Mighty Donkey!
BAU BAU!
And next we have a jingle from... Nea!
Let's take a listen.
Oh, it feels... it feels... fluffy!
No, it's like fluffy in a jingle for a night.
I love it.
It introduces each of us.
I go BAU BAU.
You go BAU BAU, right?
I'm your host, BAU BAU.
Me too, BAU BAU.
Just like that, you know?
It's really cute.
I can kind of see puppies playing around and tripping over each other, you know?
A train jingle.
A train jingle?
Tapi tapi.
Tapioca.
It could be.
You have the same sort of fun feeling, you know?
Fun but relaxing.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And this next single, this is from Ghost Toast!
Let's listen.
What does Ghost Toast have for us?
Oh!
It's smooth!
Oh, jazzy!
Sexy.
FUWAMOCO Sexy Morning!
I like it!
You know, Ruffians, it's like a jazzy saxophone feel.
I like the part where I say today.
Right?
Moco-chan, you kind of come out of nowhere, but it's surprisingly fitting, like the today!
Today!
I don't know, Moco-chan, have you ever thought of becoming a jazz singer?
Yes.
The Ruffians may not know, but I seriously pursued it at one point.
I did.
That's the first time I've heard about this.
Interesting.
I really really like it when saxophones are used during anime songs.
It makes my heartbeat really high and sometimes I cry.
This part!
This part is my favorite!
There's one song that has a saxophone solo.
And it's just like, maybe 5 seconds, but somehow it just gets to me.
I just skip to that part in the song.
Thank you so much, Ghost Toast!
It was very smooth.
BAU BAU!
Smooth Toast.
Our next one!
This jingle is from a ruffian named Yunoxa.
Let's listen.
Hi!
Thank you!
It's like a synthwave.
You said it's a synthwave kind of sound.
It feels nostalgic, right?
Like a bit city pop?
I like it!
Nostalgic, but cute and modern at the same time, right?
It makes me want to howl and blast it from a non-existent car in a non-existent timeline.
Maybe when we're back in a different kind of 80s.
A different kind of 80s, not an actual 80s.
A different one, you know?
I really like that BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's cute, right?
Right strong 80s vibe.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
That was so BAU BAU!
And our next is from Name!
Let's give it a listen.
One moment, one moment.
It's happy!
It's colorful!
Did you hear at the beginning, Moco-chan?
It's not like a shocking alarm, but like a very subtle morning alarm in the beginning.
If a morning alarm could be relaxing, that would be it.
That would be it, right?
It's kind, because I know Moco-chan, sometimes when you hear special affection songs, you kind of get a bit like...
The knocking.
The knocking sounds, yeah.
You know, I think there was a lot of thought that went into this one.
Especially because the alarm, you know, you wake up and it's FUWAMOCO Morning.
You know, I feel like it's very kind.
Kind and gentle.
It's like the beginning to another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you so much!
BAU BAU!
And our next is from Craver!
Let's listen.
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's so good!
Oh my gosh, I'm smiling really hard.
The BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It sounds like a kind of futuristic sound too, right?
At the beginning, right?
And it leads up to the climaxing BAU!
Very high energy, right?
Chewy morning.
Too cute.
Very cute.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, Kevin!
BAU BAU!
And the next Ruffians who sent us their jingle is... DACAS!
Listen!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us!
This one is like, the jingle!
Good morning!
Like a morning show!
Yeah!
We need to get up.
Sofa.
You know, in our studio we don't have a sofa, but I feel like, you know, after that kind of jingle, we need to sit down on our sofa, get really casual, you know, just, hey there Ruffians, you got your puppuccino?
Heart to heart.
Ready for this?
Okay, let's go.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
Are you talking like a podcast?
Not like a podcast, you know, but just like a, this is a morning together.
Alright!
Just like that.
Thank you so much!
The trumpet was so cool too.
It has so much of your personality.
I'm loving it.
Thank you darling!
BAU BAU!
And finally, we have...
The last single here, this is from ZUN!
Listen!
Go away!
Thank you!
It has a school bell sound in it, but it's different from the traditional one.
It's happy, it's not like a stressful thing.
King Kong, King Kong.
The good start to the morning.
Very cool, very exciting.
I don't know, I kind of could see it played at a club.
Maybe my understanding of what a club is a bit different than the actual ones.
Right?
You know, it kind of feels like... Oh, this is a good thing.
Like a computer virus.
Yeah, that way... Moco-chan, do what... If I was a computer virus, I would spy on the ruffians.
It makes you want to become a computer virus.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
So many wonderful, wonderful submissions.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
You made our job really tough.
Well...
Now, it's that time of year.
We'd like to next present you with the FUWAMOCO Morning jingle that we've selected for the show from here on out.
It'll be making its full debut at the start of next week's FUWAMOCO Morning, and we hope to be able to use it many, many times from here on out as an important part of FUWAMOCO Morning history.
You know, we really wanted to hear
Lots of jingles from all different types of ruffians, you know, with different experiences and different skill levels.
And you know, we're really happy because we were able to see that!
Thank you!
Exactly that.
We saw lots of submissions from skilled musicians and just fudgling with you.
Magicians!
Killed musicians and fledged musicians.
Fledged musicians.
Magicians, I'm sure they could do that.
Magicians can do anything.
We're really really happy to just be, you know, a small part of your musical journey from here on out.
We hope, Ruffians, that you understand just how hard of a decision it was for us to make.
And that, you know, regardless of who is the FUWAMOCO Morning jingle from here on out today, that you continue to create lots and lots
And never, ever, ever give up on your journey, okay?
Always continue, okay?
Yeah.
We want to be able to hear much more of your music, okay?
Okay.
Got it.
All good.
You better let us listen to your music, okay?
That's a threat.
Okay!
Well, I think we've made you wait long enough.
Ruffians, did you want to hear it?
Here we go!
I'm really nervous!
I'm nervous!
I don't know it!
Here's FUWAMOCO Morning's jingle!
Let's have a listen.
Okay, we're gonna listen first.
We're gonna listen first.
Okay, we're gonna listen.
You're not gonna know anything.
We're gonna listen.
Where's the jumble?
Done!
Thank you!
This single was created by SIRENAS!
I love how warm and energetic but not like exploding energy.
You're still sort of maybe just a bit sleepy but ready for the day.
Right, and the melody is so catchy too.
You know, it really feels like the start of something new all together.
Right!
Like waking up to a new story on a brand new day.
And it's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Exactly!
And that's why we selected this as the jingle for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We really feel like it fits the concept and has all our hopes and dreams all rolled up into it.
All those that we have for FUWAMOCO Morning.
Ruffians, we hope that you'll love this jingle just as much as we do from here on out.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you for the lovely jingle!
We promise to use it with lots and lots of love every time.
Lots and lots.
It's a promise.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Congratulations!
And there it is!
The FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle.
Thank you again, Ruffians, for all your creative love and passion.
We really, really enjoyed it.
So we hope you had just as fun of an experience as they did.
Thank you, FUWAMOCO!
Well next, we'll be moving to our regular corners.
First, we have our Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie?
Who's the Doggie of the Day?
It's... BOIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII
He's so tiny and cute!
He looks like a little flower.
Yeah, but he's a boss.
Boss.
Don't mess with him, you know.
Especially in his Dragon Ball gig.
He's serious.
Boss is named Boss because he gets everything he wants.
I can see the little tongue.
Yeah, that means he gets everything.
Everything, you know.
Head pads.
Belly rubs.
Food.
Playtime.
Nice life.
Alright.
Moco-chan, do you think maybe we should have been named Boss?
Yeah.
Boss Moco-chan.
We'd just be like Boss Boss.
Boss Boss.
BAU BAU!
It's time for another... BAU BAU!
It's time for another... B
I feel like it's more of like a high-pitched BAU BAU.
I feel like he likes to BAU BAU with his tongue.
So it's like... There's two different BAU BAUs for sure.
You know, boss is the boss.
Can't say no.
Can't argue with the tongue.
Tongue BAU BAU.
He is THE BOSS!
BAU BAU BOSS!
Not just bosses on a walk, but I think there was a ruffian that went on a walk for us today!
Where?
A beautiful fountain!
Look at those BAU-tiful blue skies!
I don't know about you ruffians, but I get very excited over good blue skies.
Moco-chan, you were kind of thinking about...
Going for a walk and just kinda... I didn't say anything.
Skipping out of FUWAMOCO Morning.
I didn't say anything.
Like, Fuwawa, let's just skip!
I wanna go out!
It's not okay.
I would never skip.
It's okay.
But we're really glad that you went on a walk around your office.
It's really important for you to get up and move throughout your day.
Right.
And I think, you know, a good walk will help you clear your mind.
Relax.
Just get a bit more of a refreshment.
Refreshness.
Fill your lungs.
We hope that the food check you stopped at was yummy too.
I think it sounds like it was an extra pleasant work day.
Thank you so much for sharing a slice of your world with us.
And if it ever gets hot, you have my permission to jump in the fountain.
If anyone gets angry, just say, no, I have permission from Mococo.
BAU BAU.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our Question of the Day!
What is it?
Looking at you two play Minecraft made me think.
Would you consider joining one of the construction companies?
I think your senpai in any of them would be delighted to have you join and teach the ropes on how to enjoy building together.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I would really love to!
But, you know, we're just beginners at Minecraft.
I don't even think you can say that we're beginners.
We're not even at that step.
I just learned how to move.
But, you know, if our senpai were to take us under their wings, we'd be really happy!
We'd be really happy.
We'd do our best as new members.
They could even bully us.
We won't complain!
But they definitely wouldn't do it like that.
It'd be okay, but...
In case something wants to happen.
Mococo is okay with it, okay?
It's okay if you abuse your power, okay?
Senpai power.
We'll go and fetch stuff.
I don't know how Minecraft works, but we'll go and fetch stuff if you want that, I guess.
Even if it means we die.
No, I don't wanna die.
We'll die!
We'll die for our senpai!
I didn't agree to this.
You know, we're really excited for Minecraft.
And Moco-chan and I really kind of talked about the different parts that we're excited and what we think that we like about Minecraft.
And I think they're both pretty different.
So between the two of us, I think we make a very good team together.
We don't know Minecraft, but we think from what we think we know of Minecraft, which is very little, that we're good.
I think the number one thing is still is that we don't want to be playing alone.
So, we'd really, really like it if a senpai wants to adopt us.
Adopt us senpai!
Adopt us!
BAU BAU!
He'll adopt us, right?
Ruffians!
Actually, no.
We don't want to annoy you senpai.
I would never do that, but it would be nice to be adopted, you know?
Maybe there's a Senpai... Is there like a place where we can go to get adopted in Minecraft and just stay logged in there all the time?
Minecraft Adoption Center!
Yeah!
We'll have to search!
We'll have to search, right?
Google it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
We're always looking for more submissions for your Pero Sightings, your Doggie of the Day.
We want you to share what kind of walks you're going on, and of course, if you have any questions too!
Thank you for all your submissions, Ruffians!
Thank you for the re-submissions too!
BAU BAU!
Now for our next theme!
Next!
We have... I think some Ruffians know.
I am in Japanese Classroom!
Yes!
Attention please.
Class is in session with Avin, and the lesson is Japanese Language!
We're going to be doing our best to teach Avin all we know about Japanese and test their skills a little bit at the same time.
It'll be a test of ours too.
Are we good teachers?
I'm sure we'll be fine, don't worry Moco-chan.
Don't show weakness!
No weakness!
I'm tough!
I'm strong!
Ruffians, we'd really like it if you could attend the class too.
I think you'll be able to learn a couple new things here and there.
If not, at least it'll be interesting seeing Shiori and Nerissa and Biboo learning.
And FUWAMOCO doing our best to be teachers.
And we'll definitely all have fun.
That's the number one thing.
Fun first, learning second.
We'll do our best, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And let's take a peek at our schedule.
Well, on this weekend coming up, we have our first membership stream, our Battle Plan.
But we talked about that.
More interestingly, we have our Rock n' Rawr Party!
It's another FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
It's been a little while, but this time,
Unlike last time, it's archived.
We're archiving it, and the theme is classic anime songs!
We'll be singing a bunch of songs, but maybe not as many as we would like to.
You know, it was really difficult trying to decide because we asked the Doggy Pack if they had any suggestions.
What did you have suggestions?
And there is too many good suggestions!
We wrote them all down, and the list is very very long.
And then from there, we tried to make the list smaller.
And then it was still very very long.
So then we tried again, and it's still too long, we had to go back to it.
We'll put the brakes on a little bit this time.
But we definitely can say that there will be countless anime song themed Rock n' Rawr parties in the future.
There's just too many amazing anime songs that we want to sing, so... We'll pace ourselves.
A bit.
A little bit.
But you know, Rock'n'Roll Party happens every second week, so that means two months.
And there's 12 months in a year, so that's 24 months.
Well, another FUWAMOCO Morning comes to an end, especially the week.
You did it!
We did it!
Y'all did it, Ruffians!
Congratulations!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
Choo-choo!
BAU BAU!
Julan5!
Punpun!
BAU BAU!
Sailee!
Darkman!
BAU BAU!
Didi!
Super SSG!
BAU BAU!
Dark Master!
Northern Lights!
BAU BAU!
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!